a Muslim I mean like we believe as a
Muslim and we say we believe because I
believe it's based upon no proof no when
we say we believe me we know who certain
things and I use this term yeah but
believe in God which is not true and
Prophet Muhammad
he said the house
or a Christian or a fire worshiper if
you notice Prophet who haven't never
said or they will make him a Muslim
because the Muslim means submit yourself
to God okay there was a study it was
carried out to Oxford University yeah so
they spent like over 1.9 million when
they study or projects yeah so they took
children for different part of the world
and they it turned three years they come
to conclusion that if you leave children
without any prior education they will
grow up if you believe in God and
there's a purpose
and I was speaking to this lady who
became Muslim she said she was brought
up in atheist household atheist
household yeah but she believed in God
she said when she was young and she
believed if she felt stressful depressed
she will raise hand to God you
understand and also there is a logical
proves
foreign
[Music]
so either this universe is a product of
knowledge or no knowledge and no doubt
is a product of knowledge you have a
nose next to your mouth
you eat smell food you have eyebrows
above your eyes why
sweats contain salt
if it keeps going to you I will damage
it so look to protect it yeah likewise
we have liquid our eyes our eyes is
different than the liquid in our ears
the liquid in our ears is thicker to
protect us we have to go inside the
liquid in our eyes is thinner
it goes in dries it out like everything
there is you know Allah in the Quran
there's a chapter in the pool and insane
chapter of human beings
for a man for you and I to think once
upon a time I was non-existent not as
hearing inside of everything you know so
the example always give about the phone
yeah
you and I and all of us here we haven't
seen the person who made the phone
and see you haven't seen it all right
but I don't have to it's not conditional
for me to seeing to know this one just
looking at the the menu the the
structure the options and so on settings
and so on that I must have a creator
if I say to you this phone was created
by a rock would you accept that no but
even though the rock has energy correct
okay if I say to this phone was made by
a child that is five months old
no even the child he has some energy
some power some very own knowledge why
because by looking at the product
anything no way but if I say this phone
was made by someone who has PhD how to
make a phone yeah it makes sense you
know it's a smaller scale what about you
and I what about this beautiful creation
makes sense yeah it makes sense
how old is the Muslim type who's in
favor
it's always been there
because for example because many people
have misunderstanding what is Islam that
Islam means to be Arabic you know Islam
means submit yourself to God so if we go
back to the Old Testament are you
familiar with the Old Testament and the
Bible if you go back to the Old
Testament
Moses Abraham Noah all of them submit to
God according to God's teachings yes all
of them submit to God according to God's
teaching and that is the meaning of
Islam Islam
to submit to Allah
and surrender to him and to Free
Yourself Islam has been there Allah said
the Quran in the DNA in the Life Islam
the True Religion with Allah is them
Allah mentioned that everything is a
Muslim
thank God I've ever existed because
you know what he means by that means
that everything submits Allah if Allah
wants it to Reign you cannot stop the
rain if Allah wants to take someone's
life you cannot stop it so there's two
types of Islam there's Universal Islam
and there's a legislation Islam
Universal Islam mean
Authority that everything submits to his
role that he created and so this one you
have no choice you have to accept it if
Allah wants tomorrow time to bring the
tornado you cannot change it you have to
accept it so don't get reward for it
except if you're a Muslim and you
believe that Allah is doing it and it
will say Allah the legislation Islam is
to submit you free you know and I always
give examples of emergency and before I
go to the example what makes is worth
stronger what Islam is from God Islam
came to prison five things
foreign
came to preserve Collision
the True Religion what does that mean is
that paganism atheism politicism is
forbidden that's why we're not even
allowed to pray to any creature even the
prophet Muhammad our messenger
but we only allow you to pray to another
Direction you see so anything that sent
us away from Islam there is other
punishment for it or deterrent warning
yes so the second one Islam come to
protect intellect
that's what alcohol and drugs forbidden
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why interest and gun billing is
forbidden
hopefully Islam came to preserve lineage
family marriage Heritage that's what
adultery and fornication is forbidden
plus the Eastern caps preserve life
that's why fantastic committed suicide
is forbidden there's five things that
Islam came to preserve if we do preserve
them we will have a good Society let me
ask you alcohol is it good for us or bad
for us
uh
depends what you mean
it's harmful alcohol
there is a agreement among the
scientists that even small amounts of
alcohol is harmful rather in Britain
majority of crimes it's been carried out
by people that drink alcohol
but of you and two friends go and have a
beer yeah and you come up with an idea
for a charity that helps millions of
people is that yeah and a direct
response from drinking alcohol yeah is
that bad I can give you some example you
know it is similar to someone what took
some money from the rich person and he
gave it to the poor person
so he said when he was asked he said
because this man is rich and it's full
so I took money away from him he's back
but I give it to the poor person it's
good we're not negating that is you can
get some benefits from it we're not
negative but the harmful the harm
overwhelm and overweight the good you
understand and that is is no you
understand so for example when you get
drunk you gotta feel happy and that is a
fake happiness the true happiness when
you become a servant of your Creator and
you understand him yes so our college
group is better as individually and
flexible you're wasting your money you
know I'll tell you the story yeah once I
was on train you know and then so this
is a Polish guy he had art program or
beer yeah and I was smiling with him and
I was joking with him and he said to me
don't drink I said you must be smoking
then I said no I don't smoke he said
well you're happy why are you always
smiling you keep smiling us I'm a Muslim
I don't know I used to be crazy stuff
Mela forgive me I never drank but you
know other things anyway that so I said
I preach
you know what happened deception look
Satan how he said deceive us you think
okay I wanna forgot my parents my stress
my depression let me drink alcohol then
when it becomes sober
I Feel Again depressed let me get so
what are you doing you're wasting your
money you're harming your body inside
and you you're getting fake happiness so
alcoholism
it's bad for us individually and
collectively likewise interest interests
make the rich richer powerful you
understand it's bad for us likewise uh
foreign
[Music]
gambling so they look at Islam as a
threat for their business
so what they do they utilize their money
to make Islam look bad even though Islam
is good for us individually and
collectively
by laws or are they there's a law yeah
yeah you call it Universal Necessities
you know that's why you know that's why
when you analyze any legislation for
example to show you if you do not follow
God's teaching you will contradict
yourself you can you can go to off
license
people drunk and they will do crimes yes
and it's harmful and you can go it does
it does it's not it's not okay there's
no there's no okay okay I'm gonna show
you go to the home office go to the home
of this website
yeah yeah
for example not every person that smoke
drugs
okay
no but it's alcohol harmful to your body
okay it's harmful
yeah yeah if it's harmful don't eat it
that's why there's a principle yeah
that's principle is them Prophet
Muhammad said
yeah
[Laughter]
but not too much no but you have to
understand sister look
everything if you've got extreme will be
harmful
[Music]
Society like when you preserve people
protect people's honor dignity people's
minds people economy understand for
example if you're in a time of need and
you need the money is
your hardship to manipulate you by
putting your interest to make you stay
to me what I would do I give you money I
borrow your money then give it to me the
way I give it to you or as a Muslim I
say don't worry
I have it because I believe in everyone
Allah Islam teach us the Brotherhood and
The Sisterhood you understand but what
we say to you also we I was going to
mention about before
the show keeper you will set our code
and you have
a drug dealer it was sent to us even
though not every person with drugs is
going to decline but the police the
government will arrest him for selling
drugs and they want to arrest the
shopkeepers and drugs why because
alcohol has high taxes instead they're
making money for me in the stand that's
why when Prophet Muhammad came you know
is known as that I know when God we just
need something there's no evil desires
there's no bias God wants good for you
and for everyone but if I wanted to
State something no doubt I'm going to
try to reduce the suffix fit me and it
suits me understand so my question also
how Amanda existed 1400 years ago who
couldn't read and write Prophet Muhammad
is a perfect system of life on the other
hand we have these politicians who
studied in the best universities around
the world they can resolve the problems
you are facing because that man is a
messenger so while we're showing you
here before that I give you intellectual
proof what is the creator also I'm
showing you also there's
to become widespread
even if you are not involved directly
will affect you let me remind you I get
all of us Prophet Muhammad existed 1400
years ago for longer let's not tell them
so his lifetime is just with no
widespread you understand so he looks at
the word and he said even if I'm not
involved directly will affects you you
know what now if you open a bank account
and you open a bank account and you tell
them listen I don't want interest they
say it's fine however when your money
comes in they use it interesting
he knew about something he kept observe
right now
why um what do people follow before
Jesus most people died
but you know the reason
but before that how a man is supposed to
go we knew about something you can see
right now because it
Almighty because no one knows the future
in details except Almighty and I'll give
you another one another prophecy to show
you as the Muslims we don't believe
Islam is the truth because I had a dream
no because we have a tangible proof
Prophet Muhammad he will come outside
when you see the Barefoot Arab man
the Arabs yeah the Barefoot Arab man
competing in building 12 buildings
Prophet Muhammad when he was in his
lifetime the Arabs were not known to do
that let me ask you where is the tallest
building in the world
goodbye goodbye your bike 50 years ago
with a pure desert let alone 1 400 years
ago and who's competition of the Saudi
another prophecy that Prophet Muhammad
said he said he will come a time when a
man will not be surprised with a woman I
mean in Intercourse he goes to another
man when a woman will not suffice with a
man she will call another woman
in the Quran Allah told us Satan would
inspire people to church Allah's
creation people are born healthy
everything that example I give you
imagine I said to you I never catch your
name what's your name again
imagine I said to you I believe I should
have borne armless even though you can
see secretly have on but I think
I have a feeling inside me I should have
no arm would you help me to cut off my
arm
big Notions mentally when our people are
born a man everything because they feel
something inside them then go help them
you see what I'm saying bro that's why
when you have no code you see our
societies are in the world Allah
mentioned the Quran women
who ever turns away from our numbers
will have a miserable life the example I
was going to give you emergency we've
been having a beautiful conversation a
nice discussion I'm a multi-millionaire
I will give you two million pounds as a
gift if you do take it if you do take it
what would you say to me at least would
you thank me oh of course too many
pounds are you gonna go New Zealand have
a nice car a nice house a nice wife you
know and you remember me all the time as
well you know that you're gonna remember
me for not too many pounds I will give
you too many
on a condition Give Me Your Eyes
no go you eyes is more valuable than
anything else so while we're not
grateful and remember to give us price
for free
many blessings
blessings while we speaking me and you
we are benefited from God's oxygen that
God created
if we go to hospital they will charge us
are you getting it for free
and no doubt all of us like I said
actually you want to be grateful to the
one who gave you something but how we do
it
if you want to buy a gift for your
mother would you give that your love for
your mother
likewise if you want to watch the create
and be grateful to him do it the way he
loves it's not the way we love because
the way he loves is objective the way we
love is subjective that's why baseball
is who is the message we send the
prophets and messages to teach us about
us our life and that one day we're going
to die we're going to leave this time
what do you think was that so far make
sense uh make sense it's interesting why
how do you know you're right another
religions are wrong I'll show you the
proof like when you look simple Islam it
goes in when God you know God is so
powerful
will God create us it creates us with
the tools to recognize the truth that is
going to stand down for example imagine
there's a pad look
yes and everyone here claimed
we made a fight look he's gonna say he
made a pad look she's gonna say I'm
gonna say now in order for you to know
who made the fight look we're gonna give
you the keys the kid is going to open
the padlock is the key the owner of that
key is the one who made the padlock the
other ones are sliding so when you look
to our Universal tools that the creator
has given us our sound reasoning our
natural intonation Islam goes in line
with it
I had a crazy lifestyle before you know
literally My Lifestyle was crazy but I
don't believe me utilizing my personal
life is a proof Islam is the truth
that's for me if you notice I never used
it I mean we're talking about drugs I
was involved in Crazy drugs yes and it
was a time when I used to when I used to
get sober I used to believe I was high
it becomes all the way around well I I
think I don't know I don't feel normal I
need to do something else but
alhamdulillah something happened to me I
went to prison and Allah said the Quran
perhaps you hate something which is good
for you when I'm in prison I don't
understand why I'm prison I'm praying to
Allah why they don't let me out you
understand what happened I done a year I
came out when I come out to understand
the wisdom of me go in prison because I
couldn't stop my crazy lifestyle except
by way of going through hardship that's
why there's many a hardship contains
blessings
what would you say to someone who was
born at a Christian household or a handy
household there's the same conviction
that you do that would be okay
it won't say to you look any religious
part that is them deep down not because
I'm Muslim was saying that deep down
there no it's not the truth for example
that's why I said to you one of the
proof that God create us with is our
natural explanation and sound reasoning
are you telling me our sound reasoning
I'm I've been I believe God become a
baby and someone churches not be and a
woman breastfeeding and that God he
couldn't even help himself but it's
going to help me I don't need Scripture
tell me that doesn't make any sense or
the Old Testament it's a tribal God it's
only for the Jewish people no God is God
of everyone you understand that's why I
only speak to Christians are they will
never give you the proves I'm giving you
the prophecies you know there's another
miracle of the Quran I never mentioned
that one of the Miracles and Allah
foreign
memorize there's a claim correct but
would you know Islam would Allah
all right now Allah mentioned that he
will make it easy for the people to
memorize another verse
or the Revelation and we will preserve
it yes so the claim will be easy to
memorize and we'll preserve it now if
you go to Africa Europe Britain America
Asia Muslims at the age of nine and ten
and seven Memorial
yes even four that there are two
actually no the youngest one three
that's actually yeah two what the word
let's have a letter why is very amazing
about it yeah it must be the Arabic
language
and when they read the Quran they read
it perfectly imagine all of us here we
memorize the book in Chinese
we memorize a book in Chinese but guess
what none of us speaks Chinese they
don't know how sometimes maybe even if
we do speak Chinese we make mistakes but
when we when we read out the book in
Chinese we make no mistakes the Quran
even those who speak Arabic Arabs they
will make mistakes and grammar
pronunciation but when they recite the
Quran they recite it perfectly
also if the Jewish people the Christians
the Muslims all of them decides to burn
their scriptures
give us a guideline everything has a
guideline what about you it's a
guideline our guideline becomes the
creative you understand and also is that
someone was a Christian and he never
heard about Islam and he dies Allah will
never punch him straight away because
Allah is a more just he never heard
about Islam Allah will test him for the
day of Resurrection Allah said
Allah will never punish people until the
proof has been clarified to them
understandable you know you know there's
a verse in the Quran is so powerful this
is what's useful Allah said how many
signs of Allah
what about today what is it Sunday
tomorrow is Monday have you ever heard
someone say you know the sun hasn't come
for two days it has to bring the sun
back
screwdriver for the sun everything human
creates always we need to update and fix
it the Sun and the Moon
who is atheist
he said if God exists who is a miracle
he said you're asking for a miracle by
your own eyes
you ask how complicated you know the
what you know the cameras is based upon
our eyes and our eyes so complicated
designs
don't you not think but you're not
reflect Allah
he said that the teacher was atheist so
I said oh teacher you
amazing human beings
you believe there's no Creator behind us
doesn't make any sense man
you understand do you have any questions
our Channel by the way if you wanna
watch it
Bishops
yeah
Instagram no okay YouTube this is our
channel YouTube
you can take that
that's done yeah
you can watch other videos a lot it's
all about ones okay
just remember it you can watch the video
again and think about it because I would
say to your brother there's someone
that's coming up to us and that can be
anytime which is them and Allah said
do you think will create love any
purpose
imperfection because that's when you
believe this creation was created
without a purpose you attribute
imperfection to the most high so we'll
go through it again and think about it
like I said you know God create Paradise
based upon his Mercy because the
Hellfire based upon his anger and mighty
but he gave you a free will to choose
take care yeah have a nice day